re bonsoir mesdames et messieurs depuis
maintenant quinze jours on vous parle de
certaines circonscriptions vraiment à
surveiller particulièrement le soir du 7
avril on vous a parlé de groulx on vous
a parlé de la pinière on vous a parlé de
verdun en italie dans saint girons mais
également les on ira dans d'autres
circonscriptions dans la grande région
de montréal sur la rive-sud montarville
entre autres ce soir roberval pourquoi
et bien philippe couillard s'y
présentent il y habite le chef libéral
député sortant denis trottier du parti
québécois candidat pour la caq françois
truchon alors
véronique dubé on avait affaire au chef
libéral et ses conseillers lui avaient
dit rester dont à outremont peut-être
est plus facile pour un pour un libéral
de se faire élire car roberval mais il y
tenait le chef libéral d'aller donc dans
son coin roberval une lutte qui va être
vraiment surveiller qui est pas facile
oui parce que même si denis trottier du
parti québécois est moins connu sur la
scène nationale patrice et les très
connus chez lui c'est un député très
bien ancrée il est député depuis sept
ans et au dernier il avait emporté avec
une majorité impressionnante de près de
6000 voix en contrepartie vous l'avais
dit en fait le couillard a choisi sa
région adoptive et ça ça semble charmer
les électeurs mais est-ce que ça va
suffire c'est la grande question et on
sent très bien que le parti québécois
n'a pas l'intention de céder sa place
aussi facilement d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
la caravane péquistes étaient à roberval
avec six ministres sortants rebord en
plus oui si ce exact on peut entendre un
extrait
moi ce que je dis aux gens du coin ou
gens du lac vous avez un député qui
connaît la place qui est de la place qui
défend les gens et puis de l'autre côté
vous avez un candidat qui était ma donné
dans mont-royal c'était un chef le ccc
monsieur cuillère maintenant je pense
que les gens vont reconnaître
legault dit s'y implanter qui dit a
toujours défendu son monde puis un chef
de parti que choisit dans ses quatrièmes
compter le 1/4 élections
donc la machine péquiste
patrice est très très très bien rodée au
lac-saint-jean juste pour donner trop
t-il avant roberval et à 500 bénévoles
qui travaillent à temps plein et d'autre
part et bien la machine libérale elle
est à son meilleur ya 1200 membres
actuellement du parti libéral dans
roberval c'est du jamais vu en 25 ans et
moi bien je me suis rendu là-bas
justement pour vous dresser le portrait
d'une lutte qui s'annonce est véronique
merci beaucoup aux visiteurs rendez vous
qu'on se prend qu'on se donne pour le 7
avril on va se parler souvent merci on
regarde avec plaisir votre reportage mer
noire
le jour se lève sur roberval la 5ème
plus vaste circonscription au québec le
député sortant denis trottier serre des
mains lui depuis plusieurs heures déjà
un bain de foule qu'il poursuivra tard
en soirée c'est rapportait pas on
arrêtait tout ça
pendant ce temps dans le petit local
électoral de philippe couillard les
téléphones ne dérougissent pas
compter sur son appui
le chef doit arriver en après-midi pour
sa visite hebdomadaire
philippe couillard est absent mais jouer
d'une grande visibilité partout où il va
au québec le fait de voir monsieur
couillard tous les jours dans les médias
c'est certain c'est l'atout majeur
mais dans ce restaurant la plupart des
clients présents se disent d'allégeance
péquiste une campagne libérale ne les
impressionne pas pour l'instant les
superbes lignes et quoi tenait tellement
de travail à faire avant d'honneur d'en
arriver là
crédibilité énormément présente
dans cette région forestière le travail
en coulisses de denis trottier était
prêt si oui peut-être ça peut changer
quelque chose à préciser d'avoir un
premier ministre dans le comté mais en
même temps c'est le premier ministre
partage pas les mêmes idées comme que la
population à quoi ça sert tadié ferries
parti libéral savais que ça vaut
peut-être pas chez pour le vote d'ici là
la candidature de philippe couillard
dans roberval ravive la flamme des
militants libéraux dans cette
circonscription représentée par le pq
depuis sept ans le parti libéral compte
maintenant plus de 1000 membres du
jamais vu en 25 ans ya des bons plans
pour leur part devraient décoller
l'économie bancaire chez ceux qui
m'aident à 17 heures monsieur couillard
atterri à roberval pour venir parler du
plan nord mon titre le plus important
qui rate tout le reste possible ce sera
celui de député libéral du comté de
roberval une heure plus tard son avion
redécolle
c'est quand même un candidat de taille
je dus au fait qu'il soit chef d'un
parti et on va travailler jusqu'au 7
avril et on est convaincu que monsieur
couillard gagner dans un camp comme dans
l'autre ce sont les organisations sur le
terrain qui pourrait faire la différence
le jour du scrutin dans cette lutte où
la coalition avenir québec est très
discrète ici véronique dubé radio canada
roberval